you know this isn't about last year two
years ago 1993 it's not about any of
that it's about this is about saturday
at 3 25
um for three hours three and a half
hours however long it takes who can be
the team that can execute at the highest
level the most consistently throughout
the game that's what it's about i think
it's all about
you know just really focused on buffalo
and what they do because if you start
focusing on anything else you're going
to be in trouble
bill o'brien coach of the texans they
lost last year at home in the houston
texans memorial playoff spot that
opening game on wild card weekend they
lost to the colts now they got the bills
coming to town the bill's a dangerous
team at big cat arguably a team that if
you put him in the afc south would have
won the division put him in the afc west
maybe they would have given the chiefs a
run for their money they were stuck in
the afc east they they got swept by the
patriots but still a very good team this
year and a very dangerous team for the
texans but uh you know i it gets back to
playoff experience for quarterbacks and
deshaun watson early this week talked
about how fast it was how intense it was
for him last year going against andrew
luck who had plenty of playoff
experience this year josh allen's the
new kid on the block and i feel like
there have been times this year where
the bills have a chance to get that
signature win and the win at dallas on
thanksgiving really in hindsight wasn't
that big of a deal because dallas stinks
but i feel like josh allen needs to just
kind of trust himself and and he's the
one who's going to have to get up to
speed quickly that the playoffs are a
different animal altogether because this
time around deshawn watson knows what
josh allen is about to learn yeah the
bills didn't beat a playoff team this
year and i i'm i'm not counting the
tennessee titans who they did beat but
they beat him when marcus mariota was
the
quarterback that wasn't a playoff team
that was a team that was going to finish
with one of the worst records in
football so they have you're right they
have not had that signature signature
big time win
uh i'm just so happy mike that the
texans continue it's the one thing we
can rely on in sports playing this
saturday afternoon wild card game i in
ten years from now i'm gonna have you in
a nursing home feeding you applesauce
and we're gonna turn this game on and
we're gonna be like that that's great it
feels good to be watching this game
every single year it's like the holidays
come around and the texans play saturday
afternoon wild card weekend so shout out
to texans for being consistently
mediocre or whatever you want to call it
for always getting this game but i thank
you for giving me 10 more years 10 more
years 10 more years and thank you thank
you for committing on national
television that you will visit me and
feed me applesauce oh no i'm going to
move you wherever i'm living at the time
whether it be new york or chicago i'm
going to move you there and then you
know i'll come and visit you and take
care of you do all that stuff wipe your
mouth because you'll be drooling all
over yourself it's fine mike you're fine
you're gonna be fine listen this game
you're gonna take me for one last walk
too and give you one last steak before
you put one last steak let you put your
your head out out the window of the car
like you always love to do mike and you
know scratch behind your neck
this game to me
is
is whether or not will fuller plays and
whether or not will fuller's healthy and
it really and will fuller has been out
at times this year he's also played
started games and come out i think
there's two games this year where he's
been under 20 snaps so
if will fuller plays and he is healthy
the entire game i think the texans
offense has a little too much for the
bills to be able to contain because if
you look at the numbers will fuller is
the difference maker on this texans
offense between being okay and being
elite and being able to get those big
plays stretch the field when will
fuller's out there you have you cannot
keep everything in front of you you
cannot say
you know deandre hopkins we're going to
focus on him you have to you have to
make sure that everything is covered
when will fuller's out there running
down the field because he's that fast
and that good so if he plays and is
healthy i think the texans are going to
win this game
the question is will he play and will he
be healthy
officially he's listed as questionable
limited in practice all week james
palmer of nfl media reported yesterday
that fuller is a long shot to be in the
lineup that groin injury was initially
characterized as a three-week thing this
will be two weeks and i don't know maybe
he's a decoy you know right if he can't
play but he's not going to
significantly aggravate it if he's very
careful about what he does you could put
him out there early in the game just to
maybe get a cheap touchdown because
they're going to
you know you can't ignore him and let
him stand there uncovered you have to at
least respect the fact that he's present
but we've seen that before where you've
got receivers with with leg injuries
that end up being on the field just as a
decoy to open up other things but you're
right with will fuller it changes
everything kenny stills and deandre
hopkins alone uh far less potent than
when you get all three guys out there
and and look you know deshawn watson um
it did weird two years ago before he
tore his acl
out of the blue non-contact on a
thursday practice early november he was
taking the league by storm and we've
kind of forgotten about him he's still
doing the things that he did two years
ago we had our awards that we handed out
earlier this week we had
lamar jackson the clear-cut mvp but the
other two guys that got consideration
were russell wilson and deshaun watson
deshaun watson's a special quarterback
so you know maybe they can overcome
willful or not being there because we
need to give watson the credit that i
think he deserves yeah you obviously
don't live in my twitter mentions
because i have not forgotten how great
desean watson is i get reminded every
single time mitch risky throws an
interception yeah why would that be yeah
okay yeah now i get it i i know exactly
how great deshaun watson is uh yeah
to answer your question though mike i
think it probably has to do with the
fact that the texans as a team have been
so jekyll and hyde where they'll take
one step forward where they'll beat the
patriots on sunday night football then
they'll get the doors blown off them
against the broncos at home so it's a
team that people can't trust
fully to get there and be the same team
on sunday or saturday this year week
saturday in the playoffs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports